[Musique]
à marseille les autorités sanitaires
annoncent qu'un cluster vient d'être
détecté sur 46 personnes qu'à contacter
24 sont positives aux convives 19 dont
une personne au moins fortes hausses du
variant angles et sur le vario anglais
bien sûr s'est introduit une nouvelle
donne
et bien sûr nous regardons ça au
quotidien et bien sûr c'est cela qui
pourrait faire changer notre doctrine et
nos actions s'il fallait contenir une
envolée du virus l'état doit désormais
mettre en place des tests un peu plus
drastiques c'est à dire qu'on sache
exactement tous les avions tous les
passagers qui entrent sur le territoire
national que personne ne passe entre les
trous de la raquette et aujourd'hui nous
ne sommes pas certain de l'efficacité
des mesures qui sont prises par le
gouvernement
j'aimerais qu'on ait des frontières
hermétiquement fermée entre la france et
le royaume uni ce qui nous est promis
depuis maintenant un mois ce qui n'est
pas le cas on va le voir je crois tout à
l'heure ce qui n'est pas le cas et tout
le monde le sait mais c'est une nouvelle
fois une erreur une faute un conte
préhensile qui se reproduit et ensuite
on le dira il est là c'est incontrôlable
et puis on va vous mettre à la maison en
confinement est ce qu un recond finement
pure et simple du rpt comme on dit est
envisagée il n'est pas envisagé mais il
ya plusieurs scénarios possibles
marseille dans les bouches du rhône qui
font partie des nouveaux départements
soumis à un couvre-feu avancé à 18
heures à partir de ce soir c'est aussi
le cas regardez de l'allier du vaucluse
du cheikh de la côte d'or des alpes de
haute provence se développaient des
rencontres de convivialité entre 18h et
20h et qu'on sait bien que sedan
mouvement fin dans le contexte pardon
familial et amical que les
contaminations sont les plus élevés
parce que c'est à ce moment là qu'on
quitte son masque
c'est à ce moment là qu'on se parle et
c'est à ce moment là qu'on projette des
virus le virus m l'apéro les ehpad ont
commencé à être vacciné je me suis
décembre la montée en puissance se fait
cette semaine dans plusieurs régions de
france et dans toute la france la
semaine prochaine de manière à ce que
nous ayons une campagne éclair de
vaccination dans des bonnes conditions
depuis quelques jours il fait donc
partie des populations prioritaires et
il veut donner l'exemple le pape
françois dit avoir pris rendez vous pour
se faire vacciner
il le fera la semaine prochaine et il
incite tout un chacun faire comme lui il
a aussi des mots très durs envers ceux
qui refusent ce vaccin le souverain
pontife emploie le terme de
négationnisme suscite suicidaire la
publicité allait fonder sur quoi on vous
montre que quelqu'un acquiert ou fait
quelque chose et qu'il y prend du
plaisir à mes qualités qu'un miroir
qu'il en est satisfait en tout cas qui
se dit je me suis fait vacciner j'en
suis satisfait on voit quelqu'un faire
quelque chose on veut limiter
c'est pour ça qu'on publie ci des
actions parfois une information qui
n'avait pas chuté jusqu'à maintenant
brigitte macron positive à la coved 19
c'était pendant les vacances de noël on
nous dit si vous voulez des chiffres
c'est qu'aujourd'hui aucune perte n'a
été dit le révéler déplorer parmi les
5000 premières vaccinations c'est la
seule données dont on dispose
aujourd'hui on nous assure également
qu'il n'y a eu aucun problème à la
livraison de ces deux ce sera sans doute
une réponse à cette image qui a beaucoup
circulé sur les réseaux sociaux
ce poids-lourd envoyer dans le décor
censé symboliser le fiasco de la
vaccination
ceci étant photomontage c'est kafkaïen
moi je suis circonspecte pendant 48
heures le débat le plus important en
pleine émeute dans la première
démocratie mondiale est en pleine
pandémie pendant 48 heures sur les
réseaux sociaux et dans les médias en
parlent d'un soins pour cheveux
il ya évidemment aucun placement de
produit je n'ai jamais fait de
placements de produits de pasto
sponsorisés c'est direction l'espagne à
présent ces chutes de neige historiques
le bilan est lourd au moins quatre
personnes décédées alors vous avez très
probablement tout vu tout entendu de ce
qui se passait là bas des paquets des
paquets de neige dans les rues de madrid
des scènes inédites des dizaines de
madrilènes se sont livrés à une grande
bataille de boules de neige
d'autres n'ont pas hésité à chausser
leurs skis et cette vidéo d'un homme
conduisant un traîneau tiré par des
chiens en plein coeur de madrid a fait
le tour des réseaux sociaux